fangs
who doesn't like them in the immortal
words of martin luther king
for the fang and flat-chested i'm
willing to get arrested
hence today we'll see the ogs who put
fangs on the map not succubus lowly's
god
no today's list is about the top 10
badass vampires in anime
so let's get started
we begin with a personal favorite of
mine stars from blood lad
some insight on the show first okay
blood lad follows otaku we vampire
styles
hot waifu for yumi as well as another
hot magician stroke treasure hunter
waifu bell
and an edgy half werewolf wolf as they
travel to find the magic that can bring
humans back to life
now about stars he's a very powerful
vampire he's a huge attacker weeb
he likes all things japanese has posters
in his room and figurines the whole mile
hell he even does kamehameha and calls
it his strongest move
which brings us to his powers that
include but aren't limited to
rapid healing abilities a stare that can
paralyze weaker demons
control and altering humans memories
with his saliva
and crushing people's hearts from afar
like a hot bay
out of your league walking away
next we have morka from rosario to
vampire now this show is a supernatural
school comedy that explores human sakuna
who got enrolled to a monster school due
to his bad grades
romantic experiences and misadventures
with hot monster girls mainly the show
pink-haired vampire with a split
personality mocha
mokka wears a rosary around her neck due
to her inner self
when a rosary around her necks removed
few physical changes occur
signifying her transformation into a
super vampire
her hair turns silver her eyes red along
with some very other important changes
like the increase of bust size and swag
points
morka's inner personality is cold and
bloodthirsty
she's a complete 180 degree turn from
the outer mocha
in other words sukunis scored himself
two chicks for the price of one
failing in math just couldn't turn out
any better
[Applause]
in eighth place crowley from seraph of
the end crawley's the 13th progenitor
among vampires and a member of seventh
progenitor ferret bathory's faction
he's willing to kill humans without
hesitation and use them as bait to
attract more enemy soldiers
i'm not gonna lie it kind of reminds me
of the 2010 movie predator which by the
way was a good movie
anyway getting back on track crowley is
a calm and patient vampire who enjoys
fighting any opponent
one of his key strengths is that even
when he's in a tight spot he remains
calm and pleasant with a smile on his
face
if you're interested then here's also a
quick background rundown of the show
awari no seraph aka seraph of the end is
a post-apocalyptic
supernatural shonen anime that follows a
young man yuichiro's search for
retribution
all the while battling for friendship
and loyalty against seemingly impossible
odds
definitely the hottest vampire on the
list also known as police guilt from the
helsing ultimate victoria is in seventh
place
now that's a fang i wouldn't mind
hitting in my neck archeries
no control yourself you're a
professional god damn it
anyway saris is a policewoman said to
investigate the troubles at a village
her squad's killed and she's nearly
raped and killed by the mad vampire
priest inhabiting the dead village
but she's saved when main character
alucard sends a bullet through her to
kill the priest
on the verge of death she allows alukar
to turn her into a vampire and joins
helsing as alucard's minion
police girl has almost the same powers
as her new master
but she's reluctant to embrace them at
first but gradually comes to terms with
what she really is
[Music]
brothers now before we talk about the
guy here's some info that you need to
know
red blood refers to the humans black
bloods are the vampires
and the old blood is the last descendant
of an elite clan of vampires
so now with that in mind zellman is an
800 year old old blood
his titles are many red eyes zellman the
ancient dark hunter and the red-eyed
murderer which i find pretty badass
actually
aside from a glorious bloodline linking
him to the great war god asura
he's also the bearer of the gods flame
and a legend of the dark ages
having inherited the special blood
zelman has a power called i ignite
which enables him to create and control
fire black blood brothers is a 12
episode show that aired back in 2006
so it's understandable if you haven't
heard of it before
[Music]
[Music]
another old anime from vampire night we
have ghana may a pure blood vampire and
class president of the night class
much feared and respected by the other
night class students kaname's powers
include but aren't limited to
controlling lesser vampires telekinesis
erasing memories
creation of a familiar in any form he
chooses he's got loads more as well
although controlling other lesser
vampires is a good power to have
kaname chooses not to use it thus
earning the respect of the noble
vampires
oh also one of his powers he can change
his physical form
like changing his body into an infant or
his very own waifu
a very useful power indeed
nearing the top three ears from jojo's
bizarre adventure
jojo's bizarre adventure well is jojo's
bizarre
adventures no need to give a quick
summary about the plot because fans all
over social media already did it and
still do it every day so we'll just skip
it to the list of dio's abilities
the central villain of the jojo series
he has of course
tsar vardo aka time stop laser eyes
he can freeze people with his body
temperature as well as sucking people's
blood through his fingers
and like all vampires dio has superhuman
strength
speed and endurance on top of being a
sex symbol while flexing
we've been working on the course so now
to live a long day we will thank you for
your visit as we pound the stone away
one of the cutest vampires on the list
shinobu oshino from the monogatari
series is up
a member of the close-knit group of
friends shinobu oshino
is the resident loving vampire she was
named shinobu
meaning having heart under blade which
matches with her original personality
yep this 599 year old lowly was one of
the most powerful
don't [ __ ] with beings in the monogatari
universe but that all changed after the
events of kizumonogatari
kishore aka shinobu was left in a
significantly weakened condition which
is in the form of an eight-year-old girl
with very little of her original power
her original form had the abilities to
one make people who look at her or speak
to her be overwhelmed by her glory
and start wanting to die or to take the
lives of their loved ones
also people who enter her presence
instinctively kneel
in other words she could turn the
childist of the chads into simps
two she has resurrection abilities her
tears brought a witch's severed head
back to life for a moment
three superhuman physical
characteristics like shape-shifting
matter manipulation weapon creation
immortality
and a shitload of others that made her
number three on this list
and in second place we have d from
vampire hunter d
bloodlust and od doesn't stand for duck
get that filthy idea out of your head
main character d is a half breed child
of a legendary lord vampire
and a human mother therefore he makes
the ideal vampire hunter
however since he's a half breed both
humans and vampires don't like him
often underestimated by his opponents d
has surprising power and resourcefulness
possessing most of the strengths and
only mild levels of vampiric weaknesses
and like most vampires d is able to live
as a normal human being
though marked by his powerful aura his
only notable weaknesses are that he
is while not unfeeling emotionally
remote but sometimes
sentimental he's also randomly
susceptible to sun sickness a severe
type of sun stroke
about once every five years but compared
to the gates come on
a measly sunburn is nothing i'd gladly
stop going to the beach not that i have
the abs for it well actually no on the
contrary i'm rip baby i've got a
six-pack that would make king leonidas
from 300 jealous
but enough with the flexing other than
sunburns and minor weaknesses
d possesses an imposing supernatural
aura to his opponents and god-like
reflexes surpassing even vampires
before we get to first place special
mention derived from nobles as he's not
exactly a vampire but nobody's
possessing the powers of vampires
and at number one it is of course the
goat the og of all vampires and baby
fangs out there first of his kind
count dracula or by the name he goes by
in the show aloo god
alukar as you guessed it is a total
badass and such he's got multiple titles
ultimate vampire bird of hermes no life
king
count dracula vlad the impaler king of
vampires
abyss general etc etc
like his title alucard poses a shitload
of abilities including but not limited
to
weather control day walking telepathy
telekinesis shape shifting extra sensory
perception
regeneration enhanced durability
enhanced endurance
superhuman strength super human speed
and reflexes
in fact he's so fast humans can't see
him only other vampires can
making alukar the most powerful warrior
of the helsinki organization
which works against vampires and other
such supernatural forces
like zombie nazis and i'd also like to
end it by saying helsinki ultimate
is one of my favorite shows i strongly
recommend you watching it especially the
dub
now some of you might be already typing
in the comment section
sub is way better though why dub well
why not
the setting of the show in england makes
it very fitting and the dub cast is very
good
and don't let me start on that
christopher freeman evil laugh
[Laughter]
so yeah watch the dub hope you enjoyed
this list
and if you did enjoy it then do you see
that little button right make it blue
for me fam and hit that subscribe button
as well to turn on notifications
share it with friends my friends and
finally comment on what you want to see
next time
ps i was just joking about the apps okay